so tory leadership candidates rishi
sunak and liz trust are continuing to
campaign today following last night's
hustings in eastbourne
let's get the views now of the
conservative mp and liz trust supporter
jake berry who joins us now jay barry
thanks very much indeed for being here
with us this morning good morning i just
wanted to to reflect on some of the
things that liz trust said last night
but also in an interview with the
financial times this morning the country
as everyone will know now
is facing a big hike in energy bills is
going on already they're set to spiral
even further
liz trust has said that tax cuts not
handouts are the way to deal with that
so can you explain that to me is she
ruling out of an expansion to the
support schemes that we've seen so far
400 pounds coming from that at this
autumn for people is she ruling out an
expansion of those schemes
well you're absolutely right to say
there's significant support already
available and in fact it's 1200 pounds
for
houses on lower income but this has been
absolutely clear that the next step the
government should take
is knock off those levies some of the
what people call the green taxes which
would be another
153 pound saving i think that's a
significant cost of living saving
for families up and down this country um
who knows what happens next year next
year is another year i think we've
learned from the bank of england this
week that energy prices won't be going
down in the in the short term so i guess
that nothing is off the table but liz
has been absolutely clear that the next
step she will take and is committed to
is knock off
well over 100 pounds off your bill
through removal of some of the levees
but that but that's a drop in the ocean
we're talking about uh bills in excess
of 3 000 pounds i mean the most
vulnerable the people that are really
struggling they just won't be able to
afford to pay doesn't she need to do
more isn't
isn't handouts a necessity in this
situation
well you're absolutely right to say that
it does feel like a small contribution
all of it to what is the cost of living
crisis but you know the most needed
households will get in excess of 1200
pounds and that will be on top of
support they've already received but
actually that's why liz trusts you know
the way she's going to unify our party
and bring our country back together is
by helping people by leaving more money
in their pockets through
tax cuts um we're the only country in
the world almost in the developed world
that's responding to a cost of living
crisis by deciding what we should do is
take more money away from people by
increasing their taxes that is clearly
the wrong economic priority and that's
why liz is committed to cut taxes not
you know for ordinary working families
in this country who will be struggling
with that cost of living and that's why
it's the right thing to do
so can you explain to me how tax cuts
will help people with
the immediate problem of paying an
energy bill for example and
the most vulnerable people who who are
on benefits those who own below the
allowances won't get any benefit from
the cancellation of the rise in national
insurance
for example so so how are they going to
be helped by tax cuts
well look um
you know i've already said i've been
really clear that there's 1200 pounds
already available for those families and
on top of that liz has committed for
over 150 pounds additional support by
removing the levees
it's not just people on low income in
this country who are struggling with
this cost of living crisis i absolutely
appreciate they've got the highest
mountain to climb but it's mid middle
income families with mums and dads out
working who are paying the highest tax
burden for 70 years and it's about
giving everyone who's paying tax a break
by putting more money in their pocket
i mean rishi sunak has been saying that
the tories will lose the next election
if inflation isn't kept under control he
says that these tax cut proposals from
liz trust are inflationary that's a risk
isn't it
well of course there's always a risk i'm
not sure it's an orthodoxy i accept it's
obviously currently a treasury orthodoxy
but i don't think this cost of living
crisis is being caused by people with
too much money in their pocket going
around and spending money it's being
caused by a huge increase in things like
your diesel price or your petrol price
or your gas price it's a sort of a it's
an energy push uh inflation spike rather
than the consumer spending inflation
spike
and that's why liz is right to say let's
enable people to keep more of their
money in the first place and just in
terms of who's best place to win the
election list trust absolutely is the
only person in my view who's best place
to beat kier stahlmann because she will
unite our party
and bring us back together in common
cause to take on the real risk of this
country and its economy which is the
labour party
some people watching might argue though
they might question
why are you committing to spending
billions cancelling that hike in
national insurance which will largely
benefit the better off when that money
could be channeled and targeted towards
the most vulnerable people
well you're absolutely wrong actually
increases in national insurance hurt the
people on lowest wages the most
lower your wage the bigger proportion of
your wage you spend on national
insurance so canceling it is absolutely
the right thing to do to help people on
low wages
and what about
the issue of leveling up i know it's
something that liz trust is going to be
focusing on today something you're very
interested in yourself in fact
i know that you've been very critical on
twitter of rishi sunak after a video
emerged yesterday of him in tunbridge
wells talking about diverting funds from
deprived urban areas to areas like that
the point he says he was making was that
he wants to help
make sure that help goes to deprived
areas outside of big cities do you
accept that that's what his intention
was with those comments
well i'm i'm here at home in the east
lancashire and probably what is a
deprived urban area people look at the
chancellor's comments um of the acts
chancellor's comments and make that i
don't mind about rishi's priorities but
what i would say
is i served in boris johnson's first
cabinet as the northern powerhouse
minister that sort of view
is the overriding treasury orthodoxy and
one of the reasons i'm supporting liz
trust is she is a woman of action who
will take on the status quo who will
ensure that we break this sort of
country where the cards are always
stacked in favor of the wealthy areas in
the south of england she will break that
down and she's committed to this
leveling up formula
which will see fairer funding across our
united kingdom and if what
rishi has said wasn't the overriding
view of the treasury
you wouldn't need a leveling up formula
because you would already be spending
money equally across our united kingdom
we are not but that's why liz's
commitment to create a leveling up
formula with fair funding across the uk
spreading opportunity wherever you live
is absolutely the right thing to do and
shows that she's best placed to win a
general election and unite our party but
but hasn't the north recently benefited
from the leveling up formula i mean you
obviously represent and
you're in the northern research group as
well you head it um the north has
benefited from the leveling up agenda
that's been pushed through to date
hasn't it well it has to some extent
first of all the leveling up formula is
something that the northern research
group more specifically me and a few
colleagues have been designing and
working on and that's why we're so
pleased that liz has committed to take
it
and implement it in government but just
to put in context why do we think we
need it over the last decade 10 years of
conservative government i admit
if we'd have spent the same on transport
infrastructure in the north as we have
in london and the south east we would
have spent an additional 66 billion
pounds in fact transport spending in
london is 15 higher than the national
average that cannot be right and that's
why we're so pleased that liz
as our new prime minister
if she gets there is committed to
equalizing fairer funding across the uk
i know what i would expect that
additional six and a half billion a year
on in the north of england i would have
built northern powerhouse rail i'm very
pleased to see that this trust is
committed to that as well which to me
shows she's the real person for
levelling up
okay jake berry we appreciate your time
today thanks very much indeed